keeping up appearances can be expensive
so that's why I'd be trying to swap my
pricey spa days for some DIY beauty hats
let's just say they haven't gone as
planned I've tried using a beat of
lipstick but in guacamole on my face
washing my hair a beard until I smell
like a bar so after months of
experimenting deep in my laboratories
it's just my my kitchen I've actually
found a way to use that same antioxidant
rich citrus I feed my body in three DIY
beauty treatments for my skin I always
keep a bowl full Sunkist citrus in my
kitchen because they're grown with care
by California farmers hand-picked fresh
and they deliver my daily dose of
vitamin C while getting nutrient-rich
citrus in my body is always priority
number one layering it on can also feel
like a real treat
so brighten your skin and your mood with
my top 3 citrus beauty treatments first
my brightening lemon face exfoliant I
mixed together one ounce of ground
almonds a teaspoon of honey the zest of
one Sunkist lemon and two teaspoons of
Sunkist lemon juice
gently massage it into your face and
then rinse it off the four-bed citrus
fruits like these oranges lemons and
grapefruits offer some serious
anti-aging and anti-inflammatory
properties
thanks to their B vitamins citric acid
and collagen promoting vitamin C next up
my rejuvenating orange body scrub I mix
together a half a cup of fresh-squeezed
Sunkist orange juice 1/2 a cup of sugar
a tablespoon of almond oil and a
tablespoon of honey then I rub it into
my arms legs and torso before rinsing it
off as fabulous this citrus feels on
your skin you're gonna want to wash that
off before you go out not only is that
not a good look
but citrus fruit plus direct sunlight
can lead to some unwanted skin
irritation best to keep our beauty
secrets private and finally a one
ingredient softener for dry elbows and
heels now I know this is gonna sound
crazy but it actually really works just
cut a Sunkist grapefruit in half and
rest your heels or elbows into them to
remove dry scaly skin who needs
overpriced bodies and Fancy Pants beauty
products when you can create natural
nourishing treatments out of the citrus
fruit in your fridge thanks so much for
watching for more great ways to get
creative in the kitchen be sure to
subscribe to my channel and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen take a peek
at my top 3 power snack they'll help
boost you out of that 3 p.m. energy
slump
you